what's going on guys this is Rob if you
guys enjoy my content make sure you hit
the subscribe button and make sure you
hit that little bell so you never miss
out on my sexy voice
okay so I did a poll on Twitter which
Loza guys who were new you can find me
on Twitter at comments explained I did a
poll on Twitter and I asked you guys who
should the next character that we do a
too powerful for the MCU be about and I
listed on the century the void and in
the marquee of death and protege was the
fourth one that we did but the void one
now in reality the void in the century
kind of go hand in hand I mean they're
basically the same person so I don't
really know how you separate the two so
this will be this will be a discussion
this akin to like the molecule man in
the Beyonder right I mean they're
basically the same thing so those you
guys who don't know this century goes
back to the year 2000 and in fact this
century miniseries is my favorite comic
book story of all time like it's my
absolute favorite in fact
Sal overcome a pop was at uh he was in a
Comic Con here which when he was at or
maybe was a comic book story but he
found the whole collection of this
century the original series by a by
Paulding is in jail II and the one-shots
in sin at all to me and I was like I
need to repay in kind and so I sent him
I bought a hand-drawn picture of
spider-man or a Peter of a Tom hall and
as Peter Parker and sent it off to him I
was like yeah you you kind of you kind
of deserve this but yeah okay so the way
the Centurion and the void originally
appeared back in Marvel Comics in the
year 2000 and the idea was that Paul
geing is in jail II had this this
concept where they wanted to pretend
like there was a superhero from like the
2000 I'm sorry from the 1960s that was
forgot why he was a forgotten superhero
made by Stan Lee and Jack Kirby that
just kind of went under the radar was
Sodor under the rug away over the case
maybe
and so you ended up getting this century
what was told here is that it was just a
guy named Robert Reynolds like in the
first issue
it looks like he's crazy like right up
to the end of the first issue it seems
like he's crazy because like like he
seems like a schizophrenic he wakes up
hearing voices he starts seeing things
that aren't there the dog starts talking
to him but he attacks the dog when the
dog turns into the void and then his
wife Linda freaks out and she believes
like he succumbed to alcohol again and
then leaves him and so it's basically
just like Robert Reynolds is there and
he seems like he's absolutely insane
well like he's he's talking about stuff
like I need to go back to being a hero
and I have to wake up a century and like
you know I need to go back and get my
powers back he takes like a takes like a
a sheet like some kind of bed sheet and
sticks it to his back and they're just
like wow this guy's bonkers and then at
the end of the first issue he flies and
you're just like holy cow this guy is
really a hero and what you end up
learning is that before the Fantastic
Four before the x-men before spider-man
before any of those guys there was the
century and the surgery was just this
guy who had consumed a serum that was
model
the one originally given to Captain
America but a thousand times more
powerful and what it did is it basically
just like it gave him like always use
godlike abilities like insane levels of
strength and speed and durability you
know I kind of get stuff and he went
forward as a superhero and because of
the actions of the century as a
superhero that's what inspired like Reed
Richards and Susan storm and Peter
Parker and like Bruce Banner when he
became the Incredible Hulk that's what
inspired like all of them to become
heroes was the century well somewhere
along the line this century just
vanished off the face of the earth and
nobody nobody remembered him nobody knew
whatever happened to him he was just
gone it was like he never existed but
what is up happening his Robert Reynolds
starts traveling around to like the
Fantastic Four into the x-man and to
like the Incredible Hulk
the only one who remembers him he starts
calling him golden man he goes to see
like spider-man and all these different
characters and says like you have to
remember who I am and so ultimately it's
revealed that what had happened was with
the century came the void which is
basically like the evil dark persona of
Robert Reynolds and and following this
like with avoids first appearance the
void killed like a million people in New
York and almost destroyed the entire
city and so the Fantastic Four realized
Robert Reynolds as the void and there
ended up being this this kind of device
that was created it was on top of
Avengers Tower I think was a vendor
maybe was Bakshi building but it was on
top I won at one of the superhero
buildings but what it did is it
basically emitted a constant pulse that
shut down everyone's recollection that
basically like stripped away everyone's
memories of the century and so when they
reactivated it because the voids coming
back then the void comes back and so of
course you know they end up like
fighting against it and it's kind of
crazy because like the void is like the
only thing the incredible hoax really
been scared of at least that's how it
was at the time so the void returns all
the superheroes enough facing off
against it they managed to momentarily
defeat it and that's when Robert
Reynolds realizes that so long as he's
the century the void will always be
there and so they go back to the to the
tower they end up reactivating the
device and ultimately everybody goes
back to forgetting who the century is
now this was published as part of
something called Marvel Knights
those you guys don't know what mama'll
Knights is if you go through and look at
various mobile comics they were in like
the late 1990s specifically like
daredevil black panther was another good
one you start looking at those you'll
see like Marvel Knights written in white
with a black banner at the top and then
OC like the title of the character the
reason why was because in the mid 1990s
a Marvel own sweat broke it was cheaper
to take the characters it just weren't
selling and just like outsource them to
outside publishing houses and have them
write the stories and then it gets
published by Marvel and there was a
company that was called event
publications which was owned by Jimmy
call me Adi and Joe Quesada and they
were the ones who who basically
published the Marvel Knights line and so
when when
okasada was made editor-in-chief of
Marvel uh he basically took although all
the marbleize all the concepts that were
created as part of Marvel nights and
then rolled them over and so in 2005
2006 when Brian Michael Bendis launches
New Avengers uh you end up getting the
century who makes an appearance at the
end and then you get the second story
who is the century which is the New
Avengers run you actually find that
video down in the description but that
story comes one of two of the century's
most powerful displays during the the
whole story of who is this century right
like at the end of New Avengers vol 1
which is called breakout you basically
have Robert Reynolds who's there like
like they go in there they're like we
don't know who like we don't know who
this guy isn't ever heard of him before
and he actually confined himself there
and what you end up finding out is that
that Robert Reynolds exists in the main
Marvel Universe and I can't reject Lee
how been destroyed him in it was kind of
confusing and weird but he essentially
escapes he was basically takes off and
escapes and through like a weird series
of circumstances basically the void
returns and the void starts to go on a
rampage and so what ends up happening is
like the combined forces of the x-men
the Avengers and the Fantastic Four all
band together and go to the house of
Robert Reynolds now this is what made
the void so powerful all those teams
Fantastic Four the x-men and I mean like
a full roster of the x-men all the most
powerful superheroes in the Marvel
Universe on earth could not stop the
void that the void was able to take on a
combine like all of them at the same
time and in reality it took like Robert
Reynolds stopping the void there was no
way to superheroes could have defeated
him and that concept was continued on
when you got to siege now siege was a
story and it was a really really good
story siege was a story about the
destruction of Asgard a little bit of
backstory here so there were a lot of
things that led up to the events of
siege right like you have Thor Ragnarok
which is basically the death of Odin's
son and then following the death of
Odin's son going into the aftermath of
Civil War Odin's son comes back and
because of the fact that bit Asgard and
like all the Asgardians in it had
basically been destroyed during the
events of Ragnarok Thor starts traveling
around the world trying to wake up their
their spirits that are stuck inside
physical bodies well before all of that
he rebuilt Asgard in Broxton Oklahoma as
it was literally just like hovering
above the ground by like a foot or
something something all in those lines
and then of course with the restoration
of the Asgardians the so on and so forth
they all take up residence in in Broxton
Oklahoma the alternate residences in
Asgard and that goes into the events of
Dark Reign and Dark Reign was the
aftermath to Secret Invasion
right like where the scrolls basically
were replacing all the earth superheroes
but with Ironman being director of
shield and not knowing that Secret
Invasion was happening he was basically
kicked out and the Norman Osborn the
Green Goblin was put in his place and
because he was a bad guy
he did what Magica a bad guys do he
basically like dismantled shields rod in
a whole bunch of supervillains and so
with with that happening most of the
superheroes all went underground this
led to the formation of the dark x-men
the Dark Avengers basically like
villains playing the roles of
superheroes and so during that time
Norman Osborn looked to consolidate all
of his power and so what he did is is
originally like he tried to capture the
x-men they all took off they went off to
to this island called utopia off the
coast of San Francisco and then like
Norman Osborn went to go attack Asgard
and brought in like this century and all
that kind of stuff well during this
whole conflict the century like
basically unleashes the void right like
the void is unleashed and totally
obliterates Asgard like destroys all of
Asgard and its entirety I mean crushes
the whole place and it's all brought
burn is all brought crashing down around
that same time Loki tries to find a way
to defeat the void and Loki's killed in
the process
so like the void was killing gods I mean
it's it's it's crazy how powerful he is
now like the void is not all-powerful
right I mean there is a what if story
its what if siege and it's like what if
the void hadn't been defeated and
basically the the void killed all the
superheroes on earth and then ascended
into the universe and then destroyed the
universe and like that was that was
basically it but those are what if
stories they're not really in continuity
and so you can kind of say sure that
could happen but it would be like you
have an alternate reality version of you
became president it doesn't mean you're
actually president it just means in
alternate reality version of you as
president and so with that in mind the
the void has consistently been
considered one of the most powerful
villains out there and depending on the
circumstance can be considered like an
in like the top three the problem with
this is that the void has largely been
an earthbound character but as I feel
like the molecule man Franklin Richards
Matthew Malloy Shepherd there aren't
really that many people on earth who are
universe level powerful there's there's
a few but you can count them on like two
hands the century depending on the
circumstance can be that powerful but if
we're talking about like universe like a
universal constant which is to say like
they can intrinsically control the
fundamental forces of the universe then
you got Franklin Richards you have Clyde
Winchell you've got Shepard you've got
the molecule man Owen Reese the Beyonder
which is essentially kind of an earthly
character ya know that's about it in
terms of vast reality-warping powers
there might be a couple of obscure
characters that I'm leaving out there
but again like we've never seen a void
transcend earth I mean there was a
what-if story where it did but we never
saw what happened but like we've never
seen the void fight Galactus we've
nourish him a void fight the silver
surfer we've
avoid fight you know Thanos or Franklin
Richards and because we haven't seen it
it's hard to gauge his power so we don't
really seen the void fight characters
like that so it becomes of self when
you're talking about the void versus
like these cosmic beings but having said
that the question becomes it's really
the million dollar question why could
the void not work in the Marvel
Cinematic Universe well the reason for
this is is really it's it's pretty
simple and it's twofold the first is the
fact that the void is the opposite of
order the void is chaos and the second
is the amount of power the void
possesses so when you look at the Marvel
Cinematic Universe it really is just
ordered and structured it's not as far
from what you would normally expect to
see in a comic book in in the Marvel
Comics as you could hope that's why it's
more akin to the Ultimate Universe it's
more tangible more grounded and then
what you're doing with the void is
you're throwing it in there you're
throwing the void into the MCU and all
the void wants to do is destroy that's
that's the only thing the void wants to
do and like you throw that in there
you're basically throwing chaos into an
organized system and the result is that
that organization will become chaos
literally you could set your watch to it
and then in turn you're taking that
chaotic structure that chaotic nature
and then you're giving it power that
Dwarfs everything we've seen so far I
mean I would say the void from Marvel
Comics if he was thrown in the MCU could
easily crush Thanos with the Infinity
Gauntlet because the Infinity Gauntlet
and Marvel Cinematic Universe is not as
powerful as the one in the comics when
you're talking about someone like the
void who can who has like the ability to
mess with reality then you're talking
about a scenario where like Thanos uses
the reality stone and the voids like
nope and then undoes it it just wouldn't
work I mean he would just annihilate
everything everything and everyone you
know I mean it would it would take no
time at all I mean they would be
hopelessly outmatched because it's just
such an extreme display of power but
again it's really more the chaos that
the void represents more so than
anything else
how many the void became infectious and
and literally like went through and and
just sort of like infecting people then
it would just start it would turn it
would turn the one like a chaotic place
where everybody would like fight and
kill each other all the time you know it
would be the end of days and and that's
what you're talking about by throwing
his character into the MCU
there's no real way to there's no way to
win like there's there's no real way to
come back I mean maybe you could I mean
they could possibly pull it off if like
business because the void is the century
if they could like reason with Robert
Reynolds but we don't have any telepaths
in the Marvel Cinematic Universe even if
you had a character who had like vast
amounts of telepathy and could go into
the mind of the void and then bring
Robert Reynolds out and get the void
under control then there's a way to win
didn't like there's there's a way to
pull that off but short of something
like that it's almost impossible here's
the bonkers thing if you guys think
however with all the curves we've talked
about so far all the characters we've
covered so far and too powerful for the
MCU we've covered a lot of them but of
all the characters that we've covered so
far there's one that we haven't covered
that is essentially immutable and
indestructible and is nothing but pure
evil that character is the marquee of
death and for those of you guys who
don't know who've never heard of the
marquee of death to give you an example
of how powerful Clyde Winchell was in
Marvel Comics there was a point when he
was annihilating entire universes with a
wave of his hand just wafting them away
and that was it he was probably more
powerful in the Living Tribunal to be
honest like I mean I would like if I had
to create a hierarchy with a marquee of
death yeah even going back and reading
Hickman's of engines of New Avengers and
like the model cosmic hierarchy I would
do the one above all and then the
marquee of death the beyonders and in
the Living Tribunal like I would
probably organize it in that cadet in
that fashion but that's not this kind of
just off the cuff probably I do a lot
more research to see if that's actually
the case or not but ya know like he was
a super-powerful character but what
happened he said you guys we're gonna
bring this video to an end if you are
new here to come this explain make sure
you guys are the sub button to become
part of the Rob core if you guys enjoyed
this video make sure you drop a like and
I will catch you all later peace
you